gut ins krieg wird niemals zu einem sieg
werden die demokraten auf der ganzen
welt erheben sich und vereinen sich über
den ganzen globus hinweg im sinne von
freiheit und sicherheit
wir zeigen stärke und wir bleiben
standhaft aber mal ehrlich die
vorstellung dass wir jetzt unsere
kriegsmaschinerie unsere truppen unsere
flugzeuge unsere panzer da jetzt rein
schicken unsere piloten all das machen
wir uns nichts vor egal was die anderen
sagen das ist der dritte weltkrieg wir
müssen ehrlich sein
zu unserem korrespondenten herbert
bauernebel
herbert ja joe biden spricht diese worte
ganz deutlich aus wie paul ronzheimer
gesprochen ein eingreifen des westens
ist genau das was man sich dort wünscht
aber das ist jetzt kategorisch
ausgeschlossen und da dürfte auch keine
zweifel mehr aufkommen
joe biden hat hier eine ganz klare linie
gezogen er hat gesagt bis zum bis zur
auslage der nato bis zur lückenlosen
verteidigung des nato bündnisses bis
dahin möchte er gehen aber keinen
schritt weiter und das bedeutet dass es
keine direkte nato unterstützung für die
soldaten und für die em in der ukraine
geben wird ausgeschlossen von dem sind
natürlich waffenlieferungen aber auch
hier hat joe biden bereits in den
letzten stunden am tagen eine linie
gezogen als er einen deal mit alten
russischen mix aus der polnischen armee
abgelehnt hat es wäre geplant gewesen
die über amerika weiterzureichen an die
ukraine auch hier hat joe biden
eindeutigen nein gesagt ja gesagt das
wäre zu riskant hier könnt das könnte
russland als direkten eingriff in den
krieg erachten und die gefahr eines
antiken auseinandersetzung würde steigen
die beiden habt hier die notbremse
gezogen es gab einen großen druck auf
seiten seiner eigenen partei mehr zu tun
für die ukraine aber der amerikanische
präsident hat klipp und klar gesagt
keine ahnung truppen keine
amerikanischen truppen an der seite der
ukraine
der wert war das ein signal nur die
amerikanische bevölkerung und die
amerikanische politik oder auch ein
signal an wladimir putin
ja man kann jetzt natürlich
argumentieren und das tun viele kritiker
von joe biden warum er seine kriegspläne
und seine seine ideen seine außenpolitik
so klipp und klar formuliert praktisch
alles auf den tisch legt was er tun wird
was er nicht tun wird viele sehr viele
kritiker sagen der russische präsident
könnte sich darauf dann einstellen aber
joe biden hat es immer so gemacht bei
der ganzen krise er hat alle fakten auf
dem tisch gelegt und hat klar gestellt
was die amerikaner tun wollen und was
sie nicht machen werden und das bei
dieser taktik ist der geblieben aber
klar ist natürlich er möchte hier
entgegenwirken den kritikern dem zucker
dass hier der amerika einfach zu wenig
tut um den ukrainern zu helfen und das
hat super jetzt in ganz deutlichen
worten gemacht von russischer seite
heute gemischte signale aus moskau zum
einen hat russland vor nato
verstärkungen gewarnt herbert im
baltikum und auch mit angriffen auf
waffenlieferungen in der ukraine gedroht
andererseits aber auch gespräche über
grundsätzliche
waffenkontrollen mit den usa angeboten
mixed signals wie man in den usa sagen
würde wie werden die interpretiert
absurd eigentlich wie gesagt kalt warm
kann man das sagen auf der einen seite
ganz normale diplomatie ganz normales
weiterverhandeln bei einem abkommen über
zur einschränkung aus strategischer
waffen und auf der anderen seite dieses
übliche säbelrasseln und die neuen
angriffe moskaus auf die politik der
nato hier die ostflanke zu verstärken
amerika alleine hat ja mehr als 12.000
soldaten bereits nach europa geschickt
es gibt aufrüstung eine aufstockung der
truppen in den baltischen staat
natürlich und auch in anderen staaten
wie polen und rumänien alles eben an der
grenze zur ukraine oder an der grenze zu
russland und hier das stößt natürlich am
moskauer sauer auf muss man sagen und
wird hier kritisiert thomas gaber klar
ist auch die das ist eben die politik
der nato derzeit die die aus flanke zu
schützen und auch waffen an auch keine
zu liefern und daran wird sich nichts
ändern herbert bauernebel live aus new
york danke herbert